the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to day three
of the 2022 fall chess classic as always
my name is Jonathan trance and I'm happy
to be joined here with Miro we're just
going to go ahead we're gonna go with
Miro uh on this one uh but I'm glad
everybody is here with us thank you to
everybody watching on Twitch and YouTube
we'll be covering this entire uh the
rest of this tournament here for the day
and first of all let's just start off at
the very top let's get to know how some
of our competitors are doing and let's
take a look at how we are doing in the a
group here are the standings uh in first
we have a soul leader we got vidit
gudrafi on a solid two out of two points
can't get any much better than that and
on one and a half points we have both
illianishnik and nijat absav we also
have quite a lot of the pack still
sitting at one point we're talking about
Yu Yang Yi Hans Neiman Gregory o'parin
Juan win Aram hakobian and Nicholas
theodoro and then unfortunately pursue
Ganguly still yet to get on the board
but there's still plenty of time now
Miro could you let us know what has been
going on in the b in the B group yeah
well in the B group we have Ronald
sadwani and Denise cadbridge sharing the
lead both on two out of two 100 only one
Playa tigran harutinyan has 50 and yet
once again not too boring draws but he
won and then lost a lot more results in
the big group uh well tight for third we
find Christopher you and Alex Lindemann
and we also have one player Armand
McLean who is yet to score his first
half a point
all right so we'll be seeing what's
going on there but first let's take a
look at our tournament formats now for
this tournament there are two 10 player
round Robins each player will be
receiving 90 minutes for the first 40
moves uh after that they will be
receiving an additional 30 minutes for
the rest of the game and from move one
they get that 30 second increment a
tournament that we are very well
familiar with at this point now let's go
ahead and take a look at our schedule of
events
uh while the schedule is pretty
straightforward so each round starts at
1 pm except for the last one which will
start couple hours earlier because in
case of a tie break in case of a playoff
it will be played on the same day at 5
PM however good people on YouTube chat
twitch chat or wherever else you're
watching us if you're only here for the
show make sure that you show up three
hours later because that's that's the
moment our show starts every day so 1pm
ground's gonna start and we are starting
4pm which I believe is correct and if
you do want to join us here on social
media we are live on Twitch and YouTube
we are sitting here we're reading the
chat big shout outs to Ian Patrick Evan
everybody that's here watching with us
today and if you want to get a hold of
us on social media please use the
hashtag fall chess classic or you can
watch all of the games live on
uschestchamps.com and this is the moment
in the show where I am going to let you
know that all of the money that we do
raise both on YouTube and twitch goes to
a really amazing cause for every 75
dollars that we read uh that we receive
from you guys either through ads on
YouTube or from sub spits donations that
go through on Twitch for every 75
dollars a kid will be receiving
programming for their school so thank
you to everybody that has been giving
all throughout the show now let's go
ahead and jump into our pairings for a
group
in the a group we got Sergey Ganguly
going up against Gregory o'parin today
Nicholas theodoro is going up against
Ilya nijnick Aram hakobian is going up
against vidit Gujarati one wind is going
up against not Judd absov and our game
of the day is the game between you young
Yi and Hans Neiman and you know what
every time you come up always the first
comment in the chat is hey what's going
on with the Hans and even game so we got
it for you and we're going to bring you
all of the action now
uh all right let's find out if there is
a lot of the action left right yes we're
gathering in the studio obviously
roughly half an hour before the show and
it looked like a very promising position
back then but now it's sort of Peters
out a little bit so last couple of moves
being uh F3 Knight G3 and you already
can see the potential for further
exchanges uh let's watch this one from
the very beginning perhaps yes
uh well I think he has done the same
against one Magnus Carlson yes we're
seeing a lot of nimsos yeah this is the
nimzo Indian of course so Bishop to G5
C5 D5 H6 uh that's a tricky one I never
know when exactly do you play H6 in such
a position maybe Hans knows yeah
Bishop H4 D6 E3
he trades and now it looks more like a
you know the benoni structure which is
the bishop which forgotten to be I mean
usually the bishop is here in the benoni
but yeah Hans has it on B4 which might
be not a bad thing Knight to D7 Queen A5
and Union went to sacrifice upon this
way so simply disregarding that the pawn
can be taken and it was C4 Knight to D2
well perhaps white just wants to play
some sort of E4 F4 and that's that's
actually what happened in the game right
E4 Bishop B7 uh well Knight to B1 that's
karpovian ideas we are talking about
yeah the knights on D2 is not great so
let's bring it to C3
A6 A4 stopping B5 not really yeah yeah
B5 cells traded over here C4 yeah well
maybe this B5 actually kind of
forces the you know disciplinifications
so B5 you can't really well at least if
you trust hans's calculation you can't
really take with the c pawn and the
bishop because E4 is will be hanging
right so that's why he captures with the
pawn twice C4 once again black is not
even threatening to take on D3 but you
you got to play the move right the
Knight C3 the movie you've intended
would actually shut this file and hang a
bishop so therefore Queen takes Queen
takes Bishop takes then G5 perhaps is a
very important move because you want to
force the bishop G3 so that after Knight
E4
uh well the bishop will be traded for a
night and why no longer gonna have two
Bishops Advantage so F3 Knight takes
rookie eight intermediate well okay
that's interesting why would you why
would you want to swap but okay yoongi
has his reasons uh G takes oh sorry H
takes G3 D5 that's the current position
on the board all right steal some play
there is a feeling and I want to say
like structure wise if you only look at
where the pawns are yeah and if you
imagine say the Knight getting uh you
can't really get it on beaches okay
they'll need a few moves but yeah if it
eventually gets on D4 I would reckon
white is quite a bit better okay so it's
uh like a good structure but dynamically
that doesn't work for white it seems
because now E2 is not a square for the
bishop right after Bishop D3 black jumps
Knight C5 D4 and so on so I'm actually
somewhat worried for you and me here
uh he might not even have the equal
position huh he might be in a bit of a
trouble now that I'm thinking so if
anyone is in trouble here you think it's
you Yang Yi like maybe Han's demon might
be able to get some sort of Advantage
Yeah well yeah looks looks somewhat
promising for Hans yeah but that's once
again it's sort of an immediate action
right so it's very Dynamic if he has
something he has to have something right
now
wonderful so yeah we'll definitely be
keeping our eye on this one as this game
progresses but let's also see what's
going on in the B group we have a lot
going on there and here are our pairings
for today we got Christopher you going
up against Christian carrilla ronik
sarwani is going up against tigran
hartunyan Dennis kandrick is going up
against Brandon Jacobson Alex Slenderman
has white against Armin mikhailian and
gurgoli cantar has white against oxshot
in our game of the day so let's go ahead
and jump in and see what's going on with
this one I believe it started with a
grunfeld but that's about all I know of
this one really I mean it does look but
if you think of groomfield has to be on
G6 right I apologize for everything so
that works too way too quickly none of
that but you're absolutely right like
looking at the structure that would be
my first guess but how did this happen
that was that was semi tarish so again
this is like you could almost predict
without seeing the game that every game
so semi tarash we've seen quite a few of
these in this tournament yes
often yeah very often it will be the
same kind of the same structure so white
eventually ends up playing E5 as he will
in our game as well uh well yeah Bishop
C4 Knight to D7 Once Upon a Time
this position which is clearly kind of
the key position for the semi Taurus if
you allow Bishop before and so on and
people were discussing I mean like white
has a few moves Bishop D3 Bishop C4 can
start with Rook C1 something is more
clever than the other and black was
supposed to react in like different
Fashions so for this however you play
this map now I mean you open the engine
I mean you run it and it says it doesn't
doesn't matter
97 in whatever order you like set up the
same thing and it's equal yeah that's
always the way it isn't it yeah just do
whatever so B6 Bishop B7 you yeah no but
I still I remember like one of the plans
would be I'm moving the a pawn to create
a weakness on the queen side and you
know what in more on most of the case in
most of the cases A4 according to engine
is met with A5 I mean big squares who
cares you know be six weeks no
one kind of trend that I've noticed just
with this tournament in particular too
is when we get a position like this
where at least you can correct me if I'm
wrong it feels like either white gets
some Advantage with some sort of big
attack or in sort of like the end game
somehow black will end up with like the
better Pawn structure I feel like this
is something that we've seen occurring
in multiple games multiple different
kinds of Pawn structures but it seems
like in this tournament in particular
whoever is trying to attack doesn't get
there the defender gets the better end
game and has all of the chances to win
these games is that what we might see
here or yeah look so the so far we
haven't really haven't seen a game where
let's say someone went for an attack and
was successful well perhaps a bustle we
could say in the first round but he was
kind of forced to right his opponent
went to take his Rook so he was supposed
to attack but yeah you're right there's
a Triumph of positional chess that one
E5 yeah well okay when do you play E5 if
not now right E5 and black Ah that's
lovely so I just realized E5 Knight D5 I
was I was thinking okay where was he
planning to to go with the queen he was
Planet he was planning to take on H7 I'm
I'm guessing wow I'm guessing he was
planning to take on H7 and then I guess
Queen
or am I talking nons yeah I do that's a
very common very common blunder against
uh seven sacrifice many many games
so the win instances people would
blunder this like this diagrams
sometimes don't even have rookie four no
yes Bishop to D3 and so on I was making
a case or for why h7h6 is such a clever
man that's brilliant too yeah why H7 H6
is a clever move but and I thought yeah
it might have been that you moved the
Knight and he gets but no no apparently
not uh anyway H6 was played white girls
with eight four black ends up playing 95
WS 24 threatens the Checkmate but you
can go back
Queen F4 and go back and white
thank you very much Gary Lee
decided not to repeat because we've seen
couple of times people seem happy to
repeat on first occasion yeah Knight to
C3 Rook D2
Rook F to d8 Knight H2 oh okay so moving
the Knight
uh some Queen nah that's the problem I
think for a while that you kind of don't
have the comfortable Square for the game
obviously for the queen sorry so after
Knight H2 perhaps it's clear that the
Knight wants to go to G4 and be
sacrificed somewhere
Queen E7 and now I was wrong Knight F1
Knight G3 okay makes sense yeah close to
H5
for a change it might be the game where
black is not that comfortable all right
this has been the constant struggle you
know as somebody that I guess kind of
admires the Romantic games where
attacking just seemed to work we haven't
seen a lot of it work out yet so uh in
my book I'm kind of rooting for some
sort of nice attack to actually work
yeah well but that's what commentators
always do yeah I mean I mean it's nice
it's entertaining makes your working day
shorter I mean nice attack 25 moves Rook
sacrifice fans love it you guys love it
we love it everyone's happy with a nice
attack when it actually works and we do
have a game where somebody was actually
able to win so if you don't mind uh the
Christopher you game I believe has come
to its conclusions as long as he wasn't
playing our fellow commentator Christian
carrilla we'll have nothing to cry about
on this one but let's check out what
happened to that game 23 moves only I
don't know if we will get a an interview
with uh Christopher he might have laid
the room yeah
was it even allowed when they say no
draw offers before move forward
she'll be uh should there be a rule like
okay you're not allowed to resign or
you're not allowed to win before move
25. you actually could change things
because these situations where people
want to resign but they would have
somehow won that game yeah it could
actually influence everything so so far
it doesn't look like a disaster for
black so D4 Bishop D7 I'm afraid this
game would involve some sort of a
blunder okay so far nothing too dramatic
but maybe white does slowly get
somewhere 94.95 at check on F6 well
king h8 queen E4 okay Queen's coming
over and I don't know why it's so bad
but apparently King h8 was the last
mistake and if King is mistake and you
have to take the Knight you guess the
position is terrible yeah but after King
and shade Queen E4 computer is merciless
as yeah okay
uh why it's completely winning
so perhaps you just cannot really
gotta get rid of this Knight so H6
always met with green H4 right and he
forced to go into five
well if the Christian went through B8
traded here F4 pushing the Knight away
as well H6 so I got engaged in those
tactical sequences
yeah very quick very quick win for
Christopher you who is on Two and a Half
out of three all right and I believe we
also have another game that has finished
if we can take a quick look at uh
Ganguly and Oparin uh again Julian
naparian he's actually actually right
before we get to this one too we might
actually have an interview with
Christopher you that you take a listen
to last time this was one of our best
interviews of all time so uh let's see
what we get from Christopher today
alrighty I am here with Christopher you
fresh off his win against Christian
carrilla now putting you at two and a
half points Christopher you're having a
great tournament man tell me how it
happened tell me what's going on in your
game man
um I'm feeling great and
I was like I was like looking forward to
just get my game today against Christian
carrilla as he's one of the
uh
people's favorite commentators yeah he's
a generally commentates tournaments but
I was excited to play him
and I I I before the tournament I saw
the only point that grunt felt but
in this tournament
he did something different um one deck
he never did before so it seemed like he
was trying to vary his openings
I thought that was interesting
but I was still hoping that he'd go into
my grandfather preparation but
unfortunately for me he didn't go into
it so that was I was already frustrated
on move two when I saw he went C5
against C4
and I realized that I didn't have that
much preparation already like it's just
horrible preparation from me
and I was already making things up
Knight c3d5 C takes D5 Knight takes D5
G3
I didn't know some to Siri here like I
knew this was like a Mainline position
but it wasn't something I looked at much
before the game and after G6 I was
already trying to make something up so I
I decided to go Queen B3 I wanted to
provoke him to go to push his e-pawn
because it blocks his C8 Bishop
so he that's what he did
and now I went D3
so my point was to go Bishop G5 and kind
of annoy his Queen a little bit maybe
provoke him to push his Pawn
and I just wanted to like provoke some
weaknesses
because I I felt like I needed to keep
playing like forceful moves to justify
this weird looking Queen B3
Bishop G5
now he won Queen B6 and I think the
queen is extremely awkwardly placed on
B6 because he can never push his b-pawn
so it's kind of blocking him
so I think he should have won Queen D7
Queen D7 is an even weirder looking move
to be honest because it looks like it
Blocks Your bishop and it looks like
you're putting your queen on the Square
that you should generally put your
knight on but the point is kind of to
push the pawn the B Pawn to go Bishop B7
and the and once you get this out of
black looks pretty solid because I I
have no concrete way to exploit this
but instead you went here and now you go
Queen C2
Knight C6 Bishop G2 castles castles
and here I was feeling pretty solid
about my position but I still thought
that we were gonna play a pretty long
chess game because
um there's nothing that's that
convincing or that stands out about my
position and it looks like he can get
all his pieces developed but it's
actually surprised harder than I even
sought for him to coordinate his pieces
here
so he took cakes and here I think Queen
C7 was not a good move
because after D4 I get this space
advantage
I'm pretty sure so I think he should
have went like Queen A5
because now if I take he can take take
take
and he's much better
D4
and now now it's kind of funny but we
kind of transposed into a position that
looks like a grunfeld so he decided to
not play his regular opening but it's
it's pretty ironic that it ended up
getting into a position that looks
exactly like a grunfeld anyways
foreign
but I don't think it's a good grunfeld
either so it's just it's just a very
unfortunate day for him what can I say
Bishop D7 Rick AP1
so now B6 so this is like a typical
glenfeld move trying to solidify your
Pawn but his pieces are somehow weirdly
coordinated after taste takes Knight D2
for some reason it's just really hard to
coordinate his pieces here
I think cause like the
I don't I don't I don't even know how to
explain it all these pieces look fine
but he can't coordinate them
it just it just so it's just really
unlucky because
like all these pieces are look ideally
placed honestly and somehow it's just a
bad position I don't even know what to
say
okay ba 94 95 Knight F6 check King h8
yeah and this was kind of bizarre he
like immediately played King h8 like he
had no fear of my attack with my Nikon
F6 Bishop on G5 he was like yeah who
cares I'm not getting Mega today but I
think he kind of underestimated my next
move which was Queen E4
and after he saw this move he already he
already the look on his face he already
knew that this was um
probably game over and I think he
probably overlooked this move
since he can't really do anything about
Queen H4
so he tried to like it was a desperate
last attempt to try to trade the pieces
but after my move F4
I'm I'm just winning a piece by force
and he spent a good 15 minutes here
trying to somehow come up with something
but
there's simply nothing
so after going H6 tags he resigned
because if I take I take the bishop and
I'm just up a piece for nothing
so overall it's a pretty nice game
I definitely did not expect to win this
quickly
against a GM but
I'll take I'll I'll I'm pretty happy to
um
get this fortunate win
but tomorrow is going to be an extremely
difficult game as I'm playing round
exoduani
so I'm gonna have to go I'm gonna have
to sweat extra hard there I'm gonna have
to
drink some Gatorade I need to drink Red
Bull energy drinks everything
because that's gonna be a new kind of
sweat that I that I need well we hope
that when we wish you the best of luck
in that uh game two and a half out of
three is an amazing score obviously
going into the fourth round we wish you
the best of luck Christopher thank you
when in a row today beating Christian
carrilla and only 23 moves and it's
really excellent to have him his
interviews are always fantastic to watch
caller popped up easily taking down
somebody in only a few moves and I think
I know the secret to his success you
might not know this but uh well you
might naturally know this but they don't
know this Christopher he was seen after
his game yesterday he won yesterday and
where was he after it he was at the club
he was hanging out he was just playing
Blitz hanging out with the usual folk uh
I don't know if that's the right
tournament strategy but it sure looks
like it paid off here today works for
him
so you would think he only won two games
against Grandmaster but I got crushed in
Blitz yesterday oh by Christopher like
Christopher yes oh yeah he's tough yeah
at the top of a leaderboard very
wonderful uh and if we can actually take
a look let's if we can jump over to the
game between Jacobian and vidit I
believe we have a result in that game as
well we do have two results already yes
yes we have a lot of catch-up work here
today yeah let's start please
uh once again uh I don't remember we no
we did not check this one I mean it's
like every name is a different name sir
right
so D5 trades 92 yep
I was even wondering why it doesn't say
Knight G2 E2 but one night is finned
mirror wake up yeah
B6 Bishop D2
uh yeah
that's interesting because
I think this line had seen some play for
sure
uh I mean on a like very top level
um easily getting confused like with the
Knight on F3 and E2 because it is
somewhat somewhat different anyway
Knight F4 and I don't think people
usually take yeah taking this very
interesting idea so he just captures and
says yeah I don't care about your two
Bishops I just go C5 I play foreign
okay trades rookie year one Bishop A6
yeah after this
that's what uh his point was uh wow
that's that's interesting anyway Queen
D7 rookie one
whoa there we go oh you thought we were
just gonna swap it all off
I think D5 so Knight takes Queen takes
it means right Knight C6 but I was kind
of relying on the back rank issue there
too this tactic yeah yeah
so that that's what I'm saying like the
Knight takes Queen day boom and then
yeah Checkmate on the background and
black salt yeah but I just gave him
Knight C6 not really Knight D7 it
doesn't end here oh boy check well
perhaps he has to take because uh well
he actually
could go King a chain but it's uh it's
an extra Pawn for white I imagine
I don't know Bishop B4 but yeah like
like these guys they apparently found
something I don't want to look anyway so
Knight takes Rookie's gun with a check
Knight C8 black cats too
uh it's a bishop in it two nights for
now but a bishop in a knight in a couple
of moves oh Bishop C6 intimate so oh
these guys love intermences right and
gf6
so what's the material everything
everything's uh
say rook and a pawn I was told was six
pawns yeah same as night and that's the
math I was taught as well yeah yeah
Sam's same as night and the bishop so
well it's roughly equal on material
black is something special
somewhat passive for now with the Knight
on C8 but yeah
okay uh-huh so checking your faith not a
repetition yet so he went between F4
Queen D5 F3 King G7 and somehow
possibly was like a little bit low on
time but yeah that that's what happened
okay and they decided that's what
happened here well perhaps if you just
play a move like black also can like
Gill Knight D6 if black ever gets it to
E5 he has no worries whatsoever and
possibly you might think of playing for
a win right so that's another half point
for each for vidit and Jacobian and I
also do believe that there was one more
game I think it's the Ganguly or foreign
game we've kind of teased it we're going
to actually show you what happened in
that one right but still while we're
still with this one congrats to
Colombian because he's the first man to
score something against Reddit right oh
yeah
it was finally held for a draw I mean
that that's what I mean well done okay
Ganguly against Oparin speaking of semi
Tauruses here's another one all right
and E3 Knight C6 remember the E3 line
it's popular now we were discussing like
black could play six we had one game
like this and then yeah you don't know
really like do you play with this
isolated Pawn or give him a chance to
play with that light upon now here black
girls Knight C6 and then white goes A3
uh
I'm confused okay so here black decided
to take giveaway six castles B5 Bishop
B7 so nobody is playing with the other
related Pawn because Queenie 2 CD4 Rook
to D1 so he pins the little trick plans
yeah plans to take it back oh
B4 uh what what's going on because the
next move in the text is e takes D4 so I
mean if you wanted to take one before
with the pawn anyway why would you play
Rook B1 and the answer is if and when
black captures on C3 that's a text in
the game white goes D5
and if you move the Knight it's like D6
and it's it's a disaster right so no
chair no choice but to give the piece
back Rook takes D5 well very active Rook
D3 actually pretty impressive stuff yes
these early tactics are really nice
might have been a preparation because
because those moves like you know it's
move 15 and we've seen quite a lot
already right
so Bishop E7 Rook takes C3 so black
didn't
take on B2 which probably is very
dangerous right because then Bishop E7
would mean G7 is happening okay so he
uses this time to finish the development
Bishop B3 Rook C8 Bishop F6 Queen B8 and
somehow black consolidates
and just to update the chat despite some
concerns that maybe there was some sort
of technical issue no this is it this is
what really happened in this game
H7 HC uh technical issue B4 D5 thing
yeah like like white uh losing a piece
now ah that there was there was one
technical issue I believe I I know what
the chat is talking about it's the very
end
uh okay I'm skipping it over but I
believe like with opposite colored
Bishops and not much white can do
okay so he just traded everything when
Queen C5 and this is of course a draw on
such a level and the technical issue
yeah what are they on about people
talking about is this last minute ah yes
this is a very common occurrence what
happened here Miro did the Kings
actually touch each other
not really so I believe uh Bishop B6 was
more 40 That's the move that you are
allowed to agree a draw and since
they're playing on a digital board and
yeah well it's actually very nice so
that we have that we have uh the moves
since they are playing on digital board
in order to kind of tell the digital
board that the game's over you have to
arrange the kings in a center in a
specific way both Kings and light
squares meaning white has won both Kings
on dark squares meaning black has one
and here the Arbiter perhaps put the
King on e4 and King on E5 yeah so one
King on each of the same different
colors means that it's a drive Arbiter
comes over and decides to record uh the
official results so fantastic there now
uh with two draws here we haven't really
had time to just kind of go around the
horn and see what else is going on we
still have quite a lot is there anything
that has your attention
yeah let's take a look and see how he's
doing against Nicholas teodoro we have a
chess sweep in the house he's looking to
see what his uh his partner in crime is
up to so maybe this is a good one to
check out oh yeah Ilya is down uh porn
but he will get it back guys well not
guaranteed right so the Bishop's hanging
the pawns hanging they've been quite a
few things happening in this game so
might as well just look yeah let's see
how did we get here once again looks
like opposite castles or even black did
not castle at all so you or I would
think that could have been some Sicilian
neither no but nobody is playing
Sicilian speak for yourself never would
have guessed neither Knight F3 nice well
but yeah but uh my reasoning is like
it's very rare that after one D4 you
Castle along very interesting it's it's
not very often right yeah how did this
happen uh slav this specific line of
love with Bishop E4 and recently had a
recently had a chat with someone so I
said I would play Yeah someone told me
that I would play this love like every
game they allow me with white this line
it's not for Bishop E4
so the moves are Bishop E4 or Bishop
just because it's forcing like maybe F3
and then things yeah
white usually takes and I mean it's a
very pleasant position there is not much
but I mean you can play G3 Equity too
enjoying two Bishops and stuff yeah
after Bishop E4 in order to play for
something you have to go F3 and then
when you eventually take this bishop
that's what happened in the game
promising for white because you you have
chances to play E4 and so on but you
cannot play kind of solid positional
game interesting Queen C2 castles long
okay that's not what you call that's not
what you call solid positional game
right B5 C5 after A6 are interesting C5
B6
Knight A4 King B1 C5 perhaps being not
the most popular move or at least
according to my knowledge in Black
castles yeah and that's usually
let me get a first understanding always
was that after you take on G6 it's very
hard for black to Castle because you
know doubled pawns H4 H5 opens the file
very quickly but the reality is that
black does all he's supposed to do on
the queen side and he only castles when
white has when White's never on time
basically correct right I mean the b
files already opened C5 will be played
anytime soon so well white actually does
make an attempt G4 Rook C8 G5 Knight E8
as simple as that and after E4 goes C5
well everything's hanging e takes C D4
Queen B3
and yeah perhaps black has to trade
those Queens
it's actually very annoying position now
that I see it after this sculpture
yes Bishop H3 is what he didn't like
okay
because now it's a funny that's a funny
position so the Knight is pinned and it
doesn't matter which Rook you interacted
with a little tactic yeah yeah The
Bishop's gonna take and Knight B6 gonna
no matter what you're running into a
fork yeah well however there is a five
technically and then after Pawn takes
you can take with this Knight and at
least for now you keep everything
guarded once again Irish Mutual I
respawn structure
everyone has all their pawns isolated I
don't know how how this would what
assessment that would be but Ilya
decided otherwise he went with Knight to
C7 in the game
F4 let's see five how did he ended up
being down upon Bishop C4 repeated well
apparently a lot of stuff happened in
the time trouble here I do start to
believe white has better prospects B4
Knight A4 could be three
probably cannot yeah I cannot do much
and I'd be six F5 ah and this is
annoying so F5 if you take it's G6 and
interesting yeah very nice yeah so
that's why kind of light score Bishop is
an important piece in this uh in this
line now when he captures over here
Knight D2 Rook D2 oh well it goes on
Yeah okay or it's still not the end you
have seven okay to f8 okay you have to
okay
yeah so rookie eight captured Rook takes
D4 Bishop to E7 Bishop A4 check was
playing uh
[Music]
country
to talk about it
let's once again
because we've gotten to oh quite a lot
has happened they've traded down
significantly here
so what we've seen was F3 trade on G3
our trade on E8 intermediate Rook to D1
and we left it around here and we
weren't sure if black was going to
somehow find a way to get a little tiny
initiative or get some sort of Point
yeah but I've missed the very next move
by You Yankee the rugby one is a clever
move because otherwise yeah the ball
there is no comfortable Square for the
bishop but he gives Rook D1 and now
Bishop can run away to F1 that's why it
was taken oh yeah and cops is here and
this is how black is that he first takes
then gives a check okay a nice a nice
spot to kind of pick up one Pawn there
although we can see the resulting
position is maybe a lot closer to a draw
than anything else but right thanks
thanks yeah and here we are so they've
played uh what percentage of a time can
a Grandmaster win this with black
against the other grandpa yeah I've been
talking about 2700 exactly players
none zero percent well you have to give
us that there is no such thing as zero
percent so
okay so we're definitely expecting this
one to be a draw but if we can head on
over to the B group and check out how
Alex Linderman is doing I believe we
have a result
okay congratulations to Lenderman what
happened in this game we haven't taken a
little bit yet so London one a equals in
points was I know he he doesn't there's
still one of the guys playing yeah but
Lenderman is doing a half out of three
right after a fantastic as well that's a
good score anyway uh well it's funny to
see engine you know comments to this
game because G6 is it says
white is much better right
anyway
all right so a king's Indian with some
transposition on this E5 castles e D4
and that's a modern and if you ask me a
very sad way of playing the king's
Indian because I mean of course this you
know good old romantic times when the
Knight goes to E7 and white yeah it
moves everything up on the queen side I
see one player we see black trying to
Checkmate the other player okay ed4 this
can be kind of frustrating lines though
like when you see this because it feels
like white should have some like real
major advantage but I always find that
it's kind of hard to always come up with
a good plan so it's easy to see what uh
F3 and then well there's a lot of moves
once again I think Knight C6 is what
people usually do here we had C7 C6 King
to H1 like B2 D7 Bishop G5 how well did
that's a good old good old line that
yeah I was this is why we have the King
on age one for whenever the queen comes
yeah six might be three
a five Queen D2 A4 Bishop B3
intermediate Queen back to d8 Knight to
D4 Knight C5 fd1
and yeah and then one of those positions
once again the engine is merciles it's
always says why it's much better space
you have all the pieces on the board but
yeah but kind of winning this one like
proving why exactly are you better is
quite challenging Knight F2 D7 and then
this is a famous trick like you put the
bishop on E5 looks like it's not very
stable there but whenever you provoke F4
then E4 Pawn is way very nice uh well
that that was my turn
was played and then Bishop F3 oh well so
he's not impressed right Queen A5 B four
E5 and why why just one it feels it
feels like yeah
let's see ah wait a second so that's uh
that's a trick that's a trick Journal E5
so blocks the diagonal and then he can
play Knight c2s and the Knight on three
is not hanging okay no sweat Queen's
gonna have some greens
I no longer want to move after I've
considered all my options of where I can
move my queen I no longer want so that
was fine like you only have this is very
nice this is very clever two sports in
this somewhere and he chose the B6
somewhere and it still yeah it's the one
before before ah takes Bishop C5 well
technically I would go and say that
black
would have some compensation if he'd be
a little bit better coordinated right
because it's technically for the moment
it's even three pawns for a piece
of the bishop it's still here and white
has more Tempe white has more initiative
so it's 94 96 and it's not about
material it's not about yeah you know
those spawns but the coordination of all
the pieces it's beautiful so white is
white is like really much much and it
keeps getting better okay it's a C5
self-pinning six 23 Bishop of five yeah
I mean if you have to play Bishop five
because this bishop will be takened and
this is this is really Bishop to C6 it's
a beautiful effect
beautiful finish here and Bishop B5 and
he yeah he played Bishop B5 and resigned
after making his line but that's yeah
that's he lost the will to play after he
made his move that's already well yeah
that's an excellent result for Linderman
he's on Two and a Half now he's doing
very well in this tournament uh all
right which is really nice to see what
else is going on once again a similar
situation so a group starts with a
couple of draws and B group starts with
you know
it's the right rating range it's about
that 2550 rating range where you still
see quite a lot of decisive results and
I guess uh yeah at what point like
actually at what ex read if I forced you
to pick just one rating level where you
would expect like over 50 60 of games
people start would you just make a
driver
you know respect each other wait is that
what it is is it just that they they are
respecting each other because they could
still play something wild make it really
complicated and get wins but like what's
why does it happen I don't know well
yeah
partially kind of the answer to this
problem could be that this guy is 25 26
50 to 27. they don't have that many
tournaments when they're playing each
round against such right so usually they
would play an open tournament and then
you have like five games with a weaker
Place let's call it this way yeah you
definitely want to deal with that two
three four games against your kind right
and then yeah well you probably played
those for a win as well because it's an
open tournament you have to score a
bunch but then when when you are in a
round robin like this you probably think
of safety first right I mean safety
first and then okay if I win a couple
that's nice but yeah so there is no
intent of crushing everyone so maybe
that's the answer right and these guys
2550 they might be just as good of
players but they have somewhat different
mentality let's crash everybody let's go
to 26. of course yeah and so on so uh we
got a little bit of follows actually
kind of cool to be able to see both of
these kind of perspectives with the A
and the B field uh and Lenderman who he
just was checking out his game we
actually are going to get to hear him
talk about it with an interview right
now
okay
well that was our attempt at getting
Alex Lenderman uh we will hopefully get
back to you with his interview and
momentarily but before we get to that
maybe we can take another look around
the horn is there anything that has your
attention is there another game that
perhaps we should look at uh yeah well I
think there's still quite a lot we
haven't seen at all there's still one
jump thing in the a group that yeah at
all so one win against
well pardon me
uh is that a technical issue because it
says I mean remember Hans is gay it's
day three this is
reminder yes 13 moves played 13. we're
gonna get one three thirteen thirteen
moves all right and it says what time he
says somebody's out of time okay this
cannot possibly be true there must be
that means like he's on seconds or we've
lost connection to the board I mean
there's two options and if that is the
case what will inevitably happen is at
some point there'll just be there's like
20 more moves
they'll all come in a bunch the
positions though we can at least check
this part out
so nothing you hear yet so that's all
right the Berlin the good old Berlin
defense against the real office D3
Bishop C5 and this is the move I'm not
really familiar with which is Knight B
to D2 I mean it's a movie play at some
point but it is kind of weird to see it
I bet it it does exist right it's not an
actual novel yeah we have a novelty here
uh right it's a black girl's Knight D4
you told me it was a Berlin like a
second ago this is we got something new
here we at least got something
interesting
so I want to say was the Knight on C3
the now once again it won't be anything
but because there is this line in four
nights right it's a four nights opening
Bishop B5 and then they go Knight D4 and
something similar happens but okay
anyway this one is just a good position
for black okay
D5 yeah Knight takes Bishop takes
C3 Bishop to B6 e takes D5 and this is
where we're thinking there's a
transmission error uh no no no no yeah
why I'm pausing is that black could take
on
that could take on D5 there is no
problem he just kills Bishop G4 Castle
says I'm not gonna take your Pawn later
not in Rush whatsoever not at all
worried that C4 will protect the pond
you know sometimes when my pawns are
protected I just say what would happen
if I protect my body however the next
move could be you know the next move
could be a problem in transmission
because it says G3
okay you think maybe it was G4 yeah like
G4 I can't believe like other than G4
you're probably fine three is a bit
strange five six better moves this
actually is the kind of thing that might
cause one of these errors in
transmission maybe he meant G4 but the
computer registered it as G3 and then
the subsequent moves didn't make any
sense and the computer gave up and okay
when that happens the Arbiter or
somebody that's working the machine will
put them in manually uh which just means
we will still get all of the moves
correct it might just take us a little
bit of time so we're imagining maybe G4
was haven't maybe bishop to G6 I don't
know let me just play I'll just guess
one more move after that yeah so I guess
it's G4 Bishop G6 he's fair and this is
maybe what happened in the game so
hopefully we get the result of that at
some point so uh we are going to try for
the Alex Linderman once again and uh
let's see if we can hear him this time
all right I'm here with Grandmaster
Alexander Linderman fresh off of his
victory against Grandmaster Armand you
know Alex tell me how you did it you
know give me the scoop you're on two and
a half points now it's an amazing score
how about you tell me all about your
game
oh well he surprised me on move one uh
when uh you know after D4 he played G6 I
haven't really seen him do that as of as
of late I mean usually he plays he
played solid openings like um
um
like slav defense or
or
Queen's Gambit accepted so I was
focusing on that but yeah he surprised
me I mean G6 is sort of an attempt to
try to play for a win which I guess
because he was starred Owen two he
wanted to get some kind of a interesting
fight so I was already not sure which I
mean there are many directions I can go
for many lines I can choose between okay
so I ended up playing um
King's Indian and at first I was
slightly regretting uh what I did
because I sort of
um fell into his prep a little bit
because earlier like about one year ago
I had a game with Bishop 4 so but I
figured um it's in a database he
probably also prepared for that so I
decided to play a different line
still seemed to know it pretty well but
looks like at some point I surprised
them a bit somewhere and got him out of
book and uh
yeah here I think I
had to make an important decision after
Queen B6
um that it was okay to allow A5 followed
by A4
because I have this uh key move Bishop
E3 pushing his Queen back
and so here it's not so easy for him to
because for example if you played Queen
before thought I can go Knight D4
um
you know Knight E5 and let's say Knight
C2 and then like for example after this
Rook B1 so yeah the the Tactical lines
didn't seem to work and once he played
Queen d8 I felt
quite good about my position I thought
I've more or less Consolidated and uh
should be slightly better and uh you
know and then yeah and then at some
point another critical moment was when
um
he played Knight C5 I played like this
and then I had to make a decision
whether to play F4 or not F4 is of
course a very concrete move based on the
idea if Bishop takes I take with the
queen and I protect E4 and after Bishop
G7 I go Bishop F3
um and if Knight F6 I thought I could
take on C6 uh which apparently it's
playable for him but I thought it's good
for me
um
and so yeah he played Queen A5 which I
actually anticipated and I saw that and
I think yeah here he probably is
completely fine
had I not had the move
E5 uh which is the point is if I go
Knight C2 immediately he takes on C3
um but by playing E5 I disturb his
Harmony cut the communication between
the bishop and the Queen and after this
he has to lose a piece and so now he has
to decide how to lose the piece and I
guess he didn't choose the best way to
give it away although I thought it was
very logical and uh here I already
thought I'm doing very well uh like from
here on I thought I was better and maybe
he could have defended better but I
think pretty much
um
um I think I converted it well and uh
yeah
um yeah I was able to win looks like a
clean game so I guess I'm pretty happy
with it
well that's always lovely here thank you
for coming on Alex and we wish you great
luck tomorrow in your next round all
right thank you
that was Alex Linderman who now sits at
two and a half out of three a fantastic
start for him very nice to hear his
insights this E5 Knight C2 this little
tactic here was uh it was very nice very
clever and uh happened to help him win
that game
um all right Jonathan so two and a half
for him two and a half for Christopher
you but we had two people and two out of
two let's point out what's going on
there any one of those will continue
this hundred percent straight it's not
so easy to do around around day three
you should start seeing things drop off
but every now and then oh yeah someone
makes a big run do we have somebody
running uh wow that's a very very messy
position for uh yeah let's pull this one
coverage and Jacobson yeah what is
happening here so yeah yeah believe it
or not it was uh well with some
transposition it was jokopiano the quiet
game yeah yeah tend to be not so quiet
and coverage did play it in the in the
first round I guess Bishop G5 and so on
right it wasn't it was a little slightly
different so black didn't have D6 and
black went with Bishop E7 but all I'm
saying he is known to yeah develop his
Bishop before playing Knight D2 castles
and black oh well I've never honestly
never understood this one I mean if you
go H6 G5 already I mean what's the point
castling but yeah black does it from
time to time a tree can get shade can
get shade is logical because you wanna
eventually go F7 F5 and I believe that's
what was done at some point Knight H7
King H1 F5
whoa that's um
that's a complex game B5
and everyone takes everybody I don't
know what's going on so take some D7
Queen D2 some checks on Long diagonal I
suspect No rookie one Knight T5 wow
beautiful beautiful 95 cannot be taken
of course Bishop C5 Bishop d55.
getting lost ah Queen D5 this time all
right okay yeah attacking these guys
also maybe on that F7 and
let's see okay that's so interesting I
mean okay A4 you know what very solid I
actually care about my pawns yeah I mean
no because it felt like he's going for
some more loud right yeah
okay just went all the way up I was
waiting to see the Haymaker but uh age
five Knight F7
traded everything H4 not the vision yeah
tell me where this bishop goes the
bishop looks trapped right
um
tell me tell me why I'm not trapped
please
there is this move which he might have
hoped for no he actually got a gun for
something else and it would perfectly
work because both Bishops are hanging
yeah but I guess Bishop D3 is what you
don't like here because it attacks the
rook and yeah the kind of Rook D1 you
would think but both Bishops are still
hanging but this one is not in fact
because there is
I don't know but who knows maybe he has
everything planned because
with rookie seven so now I suspect that
no I don't suspect anything never mind
yeah what's that no I thought like what
do you think take Stakes at least
the f file opens and maybe white gets
somewhere uh which is not guaranteed
after Bishop D3 but the worst it is that
Bishop still has nowhere to go yeah so
black and black can still kind of play
some me but I don't know what movie he's
going to play alternative Knight F6 or
something our tournament leader is in
quite a bit of a trouble with white it
would seem or he's about to be the
biggest genius you've ever seen because
he's really playing with fire though
that's a crazy it's just weird to see
this if he doesn't have it I'm so
excited wait he saw the bishop getting
himself tempted to press this button oh
no don't hit the button all right he's
in trouble he's in trouble and I feel
very confident in saying that Brandon
Jacobson is absolutely winning so it
looks like the bishop just got trapped
wait how did wait how he saw the bishop
getting trapped a mile away like it's
not like yeah I think in like A4 the
move that surprised us maybe he wasn't
the best move because yeah but here is
there like anything else does white need
to do something different here did his
Bishop just get trapped
yeah he could yeah well actually like
you you similarly can play H3 at the
very least right like H4 Bishop goes and
maybe you drop a pawn or something very
confused so he must he thought he had
something yeah so he probably was
relying relying on this trick with
Bishop E5 or another one now that I'm
thinking even kind of rookie five is a
he's a he's a funny man because you you
attacked this guy and The Rook is not
hanging and he also attacked this guy
because say if Bishop just goes away
which is fine then you actually take
yeah all right yeah that's crazy but I
have something's wrong about this line
as well since he didn't go for it yeah
okay so everybody had something which is
yeah that's a crazy game that's a crazy
game where the guy leading it all this
is not something you would expect to see
why the sack we've got one more result
we've got one more result this has
happened gergely just one party oh okay
that that's what I have all right let's
check this one I have so white has one
in this one that we've
we've seen something yeah well that
that's semitarish fake green you know
this is the one we were like hey maybe
somebody will actually get an attack and
win a game yeah well let's see let's see
if that's what tonight to be five yeah
the Knight can't be taken because Rook
on C2 is hanging but white trades and
yeah well perhaps that's kind of
making the entire circle with the Knight
right I took kind of Knight C3 B5 C7 D5
uh it takes time consuming I want to say
right and the achievement that they only
trade the pair of Rooks which white
could not bring to attack anyway perhaps
wasn't the best because now after Rook
G3 already the computer is not very
happy with Black's position G6 allows
Bishop takes G6 and
yeah that that's bad that's bad it's
still I was still possible to fight with
it's our greatest threat here who is
Bishop
was Bishop C8 as computers a great
straight funny uh threat funny enough is
Knight to to G7 to attack H6 spawn and
D6
yeah so that that's what the boat does
after Bishop C8 foreign
was played hoping for white to take it
then he would block with the queen but
then once again funny Knight G7 oh if
that's the move and he found it seven
and he found it and it led to
intermediate resignation because he
can't really can't really do it a very
nice attacking idea to be aware of does
this blocking of the queen yeah and he
had to maybe see this when he went in
for this sacrifice on Jesus exactly
after the attack yeah well perhaps
everything is winning but I mean if you
want to finish in style maybe you can do
it blocks your queen now we block your
rook and the queen is you're threatening
two checkers
impossible to stop anyway so yesterday
we've seen uh uh well how many that was
when we were leaving it was three wins
with black right yeah in the B group so
now we have three wins with white and
not a single draw yet wow all right and
we actually are going to be able to hear
from Ganguly himself he'll be able to
give us a little bit of insights into
this game with an interview
uh sorry we will be having gergy cantar
giving us this interview uh right now
all right I am here with Grandmaster
Contour fresh off his win against
Grandmaster aksha Chandra tell me all
about your win you know break me break
it down for me and just give me all the
information Man Okay so this was round
three in the first two runs I didn't
really get the results I could have or
wanted so now I was like really hungry
for a win and uh that's that's why I
played I think a quite aggressive
Dynamic game so my opponent used to play
the semitar rush in the past and he did
play the Scimitar rush now as well so
this is basically for Knight f60 46
Knight f3d5 Knight C3 C5 we played here
the main line take on D5 Knight takes D5
E4 Knight c b c c d c d Bishop B4 Bishop
D2 take take care so Bishop C for B6
line Sorry Knight D7 Castle B6 Rook 81
Bishop B7 Rook F1 and here the main move
is a rook C8 after Bishop B3 I prepared
a little bit so that's like the main
Theory but he saw he played here Knight
F6 which kinda was a little bit
surprised to me uh because that's not
what they play here mostly and here I
was thinking a lot one of my ideas are
to play here D5 immediately
and uh the thing is that he has to take
this D5 ede Queen D6 was the move
imagined because if blacks plays this
line with Rook say Bishop B field after
Knight F6 then I know D5 Ed is better
for five but I think the difference I
see that black can play Queen D6
and uh let's say I play something like
Knight H4 he can put it up a play Just
G6 or something that's not much so I
should uh
Uber
look I just
oh okay okay
so here Knight D4 is a critical move I
think and here
I wasn't sure whether Queen C5 is
working for him
maybe it's not
okay so my calculator was the best night
at five here it does work
okay anyway I uh so after the Knight D4
he plays probably G6 as well and uh
and it's normal position for him anyway
I played the queen F4 after a lot of
thinking which was also like a very
reasonable move Bishop C8 Rook C8 and
here Rook D3 so that's I thought that I
could use this because uh now
the main ladder if you start it looks at
my Bishop is already it has to go to B3
but now it might be better on D3 because
of King side attacks he played Queen C7
here Queen H4 looked like a decent move
as well while I played E5
and uh he played here H6
okay so probably black is absolutely
fine here I didn't play the Black the
most accurate puts in opening but I
still I think my position is like uh I
do have tactical chances I played H4 he
played Knight D5 Queen E4 and Knight F6
so he wanted to make a draw and uh yeah
so we repeat Advanced but after that I
went to Queen G4 like I really didn't I
really wasn't interested to making a
draw even though I felt like black
should be fine here
uh he played Knight C3 first of all I
thought Rook C1 is logical here but then
I thought maybe Rook D2 and I can
protect A2 pawn and the D4 Pawn also
because of you know let's say Bishop H6
checks with a little so you can actually
take on the former Queen and here my
opponent I think
didn't play quite accurately so here I
don't know what was like maybe bishop D
D5 would have been a strong move and uh
but I don't know the fact that I should
play here A3 then which would be fun
after the Google theme or I have time
for Knight H2 but then maybe he can take
on eight with the Knight and I do have
some composition with Knight F1 ig3 but
it's a better version than what happened
in the game maybe I've played Just A3
but then
no but then black is fine so I should
have just sacrifice my Pawn anyway he
played Rook have DS which I was thinking
a little bit of mistake
because actually because the default is
not weak and uh should have skipped the
Rooker f8 because then F5 he he has F5
IDs later on now I played Knight H2
which was a very good move and here my
opponent has to stick it for a lot and
it was clear that he currently came up
with a plan and
it's also not so easy for him he played
Queen E7 and I played Knight F1 there
were other options like rookie free for
example but there may be an id5 Rook G3
and he has F5
probably
uh but okay Queen H5 is also an
interesting option with the Rook takes
D4
we should pay Seven but okay Queen
before the computer says that here right
doesn't create any attack but in a game
practical game this does look like I
think a dangerous attack but probably
it's not anyway I play Knight F1 because
what was the most accurate move and uh
here he just basically engage 8 I played
Knight G3 unless it's a plastic formula
that the engine still says like black is
very fine here and like nothing is there
in a game here I was already quite
optimistic in Knight H5 and every kind
of move so I've definitely optimistic
here I was located in Knight D5 for a
while
but then maybe if we need four nice
private levels like that he has to come
back with the knight at some point
because
otherwise I have all the squares we did
my knight on f4 on F6 later on he played
here Rook C7
and Knight H5
and queen f8 and yahiruki free was my
initial option or initial idea but then
I came up with the idea that maybe Rook
C2 is like a trickier move
the thing is that he will go back 95 and
I take a system electron and then then I
will play Rook E3 and it felt like to me
that uh it's better to exchange these
two Rooks because then he will have only
one rook in the end to defend against
King side attacks so here actually
hey I was thinking maybe Knight D5 I
wasn't sure if
four verse anyway 95 okay says computer
just says that I can take a system which
has happened in the game but this was
probably a mistake for him that was what
he should have played and then rookie
three Knight E5 take on C7 take on C7
Rook G3
and maybe he has here G6 it's always a
question whether he has G6 or not
because in the game I believe I could I
sacrificed Logistics and I think it was
feeling bad here
maybe it's it's not winning let's say he
probably
has here some move
that's so clear but probably it's not
winning I mean
okay
okay so here he played Knight B5 I took
on C7 okay so Rook takes D4 I have
Knight F4 and Knight C7 Knight G6 for
example so that's that's bad
he took back and then yeah rookie free I
think of strong move and he played
Knight D5 and that was the most
electricity that through G3 and G6 and
here yeah I took on G6 which uh since I
opened up
very low on time I believe it's a nice
practical decision although any move
here is like good for me at this
position but I like this move a lot so
here yeah I believe Queen GA 1090 97 was
the two move I calculated screenshot I
have Knight G7 I think which is well I
have everything else also 97 is the good
move and that Queen takes 360k and I was
like
let's say you play something like Knight
F5 I have always Knight F4 that's one of
the important tricks he plays Bishop D5
I have PNG for
and I just I think I'm just better
Bishop C8 I have Queen C4 probably
but that's what he should have played he
played tier Queen E7
and I believe and yeah he's out of the
97 which was just game over immediately
27 as he played it with like one second
or something so he played this movie
because he was in a deep time trouble
and now if somebody just came over
play your last round obviously going in
with 50 I bet you're feeling pretty good
right now obviously we hope to see you
back in the studio in another time and
yeah me too I can play games after I
would like to come to the studio winning
winning positions like that's the most
important that's the hardest thing for
me usually obviously sometimes it can be
like that we'll wish you good luck in
the later rounds thank you
that was gurgelli cantar on his win over
akshat Chandra he came into the day with
half a point out of two he had at some
moment the opportunity to get some
repetition and just take a draw but he
took his opportunity he played for an
attack and he was able to win a
beautiful game oh yeah
uh you know what you know what Jonathan
not only this one win a boss of game was
kind of fixed
the machine registered G3 but clearly it
was G4 that was played I'm assuming it
wasn't yeah it was G4 the actual G4 was
here late and Morrow with the game is
finished already
yeah yeah it happens to be won by we had
to wait for our Christmas presents but
we can have them all at once yeah so G4
and instead and Knight takes C5
and D4 so black in fact sacrificed two
pawns right one can be uh taken but he
decided ah okay he decided to win back
this one Bishop F4 Bishop G3
upper Pawn uh King's position slightly
awakened but not really Queen
F6 and this might have been this might
have been a mistake I mean queen F6
because D6 and then Bishop D5 if the
pawn is taken so black one troop d8
Bishop D5 anyways and you probably have
to part with one of the with one of the
Rooks for the bishop because yeah if you
move away it's dc7 and that's perhaps
too much yeah so Rook takes Bishop takes
Pawn takes and oh two exchanges down
okay uh well I mean there are some like
Bishops like in the keys
wait a second so seriously doesn't it
last time the g-pawn moved it was a
technical glitch is this one a technical
glitch what is G5 not now you honestly
now I'm cheating of course because G5
happens to be the only the only thing to
win
he is threatening like Queen F4 or queen
E5 to get to G3 okay and because this F2
Pawn is pinned he'll be threatening well
at the very least the Perpetual right so
he's somehow colleague has to get a
square from here from which he protects
G3 right so G5 is amazing and then yeah
like if I go as planned queen of four or
queen E5 that will be they'll be Queen
G4 right there black one Queen E5 Queen
24 G6 but then that gives white yeah the
opportunity to just bring stuff in and I
guess like Rook D okay he captured I
guess Rook D5 would have been five
possibly whatever sure rookie three
Hackensack exchanges too yeah that's
what they say like the the advantage of
two Bishops yeah one part of the
advantage of two people that you can
trade right how about two x-ray
exchanges you can always return one bag
yeah yeah
and yeah and here while black was
fighting of course but it happened to be
yeah Queen's traded
he always speculates please it's just
one you can have one
ah yeah and he was all right and he was
able to win this one wonderful okay so
and I believe if we can actually take a
look at the the win game the one win
game uh I believe we have some sort of
update but that's the one that's the one
one win against abbasov all right and I
believe we actually do have the winner
so we're going to be able to hear to
want to win and get his guidance
yeah maybe he'll tell us about it let's
hear
all right I am with Grandmaster Gwen
right after his victory tell me all
about your Victory and you know break
break it down for the people you know
tell us all about it
all right so
um today I played my good friend ninja
the bossov and uh
yeah I kind of expected the Berlin but I
didn't have any special idea because
it's like almost impossible these days
right so I played Knight bd2 which is
kind of a sideline
and the idea was that after the main
move Knight to D4
um I I prepared Bishop A4 and here the
main move is a short Castle
after which I would have played Castle
as well and here's it's a quiet position
but I had some small ideas there
um nijat played B5 instead which is
quite a fighting move I was not uh
prepared here but I knew that it was
slightly inferior to Castle and I should
have a small Edge so I played Bishop B3
and here I think the normal way to play
is D6
probably I would play Knight 64 Bishop
T4 maybe A4 or castle and it looks or C3
I mean it looks reasonable for white um
probably a small Edge looks a bit like
archangels Marshall whatever but he
played D5 which shocked me actually
but I could not really refute it I think
what I played was reasonable Knight 64
is kind of a safe option
here he takes D4 was a possibility but I
think I have E5 Knight G4 and short
Castle
and his Knight on G4 is a bit misplaced
if long term if you can consolidate a
center with C6 then my Bishop is a bit
dead but the thing is concrete there is
Knight F3 H3 coming so I think I should
have an edge
so he played Bishop takes D4 instead I
played C3 Bishop B6 and here I spent
like 30 minutes thinking yeah maybe 40
minutes
because uh it felt to me like he's okay
if suddenly after a very strange play
like I could play short Castle but then
Bishop G4 Queen E1 and de4 I could not
refute
this position 94 Queen D3
and I think it's okay for him
so I played e65 instead I was not very
happy to be honest because Bishop G4
Knight F3 here I thought Queen D6 was
maybe interesting I don't know
um obviously the computer disagrees I
was gonna play short Castle short Castle
A4 but it's a very sharp position like
uh
this pin is like
forever unless I go H3 G4 and then my
king is weak and I have almost no time
on move 13 so
it would have been very tough
practically speaking
but he played Short Castle which I was
happy to see because now I can break the
pin immediately by playing H3 Bishop H5
G4
um Bishop G6 Knight takes E5
and
um yeah well we're transforming into a
position
uh where I'm upon up so after uh 17 Rook
takes E5
um
I played Bishop F4 which is uh normal
Rook E4
Bishop G3 and here I just didn't see his
compensation because although my king is
a bit weakened his pieces are not
coordinating and I have a threat D6
which came he played 19 Queen F6 D6
and it's just very battering because if
c66 Bishop T5 I mean he can set the
exchange and get the light Square Bishop
but I'll just move my king somewhere and
go F3 and he just has no real
conversation so he went Rook d8 instead
um move 20 and then I played Bishop D5
um Rook takes D6 I was very surprised to
see
um Bishop D6 cd6 because he sacrifices
two exchanges right but here at first I
was almost gonna play King G2 already
and then okay he can still play after
Rook F4 f3h5 it was not so easy yet
because my king is permanently weak but
then I just noticed that I can play
Bishop takes E4 Bishop takes E4 and here
only move G5 because if not for G5 he'll
go Queen F4 and I might get made it so
yeah but G5 just kills the game he goes
Queen E5 Queen G4 and um two exchanges
up
um and now it's just a matter of
technique after okay I mean we played
some moves and um
yeah almost 30 after H4 B4 was his last
try to open up the position and kind of
weaken the king but I think uh Rook f131
was very precise to just uh sort of keep
everything under control and Bishop
takes E3 never works because he's the
one getting mated so B Tech C3 B Tech C3
King H6 yeah he's offering the queen
trade after Queen G5 Queen G5 a G5 King
G5 but it's like not so clear because
his Bishops are regarding everything
he'll come with a king player five G5 so
I didn't want to give him this end game
so I played the C4 instead move 33 and I
think it was very strong because now I
threatened Rook takes E4 and I don't
give him the C3 Pawn so he so he went
Queen E5 to keep it a bit more
complicated but now I can just remove my
Rook rookie one and C3 is no longer
hanging and he has immediate issues with
the bishop on e4
so he went Bishop C7 but now it's just
very bad because Queen G5
I'm trading queens and after King 6 G5 I
can go F3 and just collect on D5 and
then
um I'm just an exchange up in the end
game and the king is cut off on the
e-files it's just resignable later I
came with the King
um
to
to the queen side and he just resigned
well obviously that's a great way to
play the third round two draws and one
win going into your fourth round how are
you feeling
um yeah I'm feeling good uh so far I've
had um
I mean I had two rather easy black games
against strong opponents so that was uh
that was very nice and today
I actually didn't expect to really win
because he's so solid and when I saw the
Berlin I was a bit
um
disappointed but uh in the end it was
great and uh yeah looking forward to my
tomorrow's game all right we're looking
forward to seeing it good luck in the
next round man thanks
that was tie-dye Von Nguyen on a big win
that brings them all the way up to two
out of three points mentioning there at
the very end that he was a little bit
worried about it being a Berlin but it
wasn't just your ordinary boring Grand
Master Berlin we saw some really
exciting stuff we saw two exchange
sacrifices and then G5 which I could
have sworn was some sort of technical
glitch or some sort of big mistake no it
was in fact the best and only move so
fantastic stuff there
okay Jonathan getting more results Ilya
niznik actually saves this I don't know
how problematic it was but he wasn't
here remember the end game pawned down
opposite colors Bishops well it took him
some time in fact because white perhaps
was put in some problems there
but eventually yeah eventually they
finished in the drugs obviously wait a
second check
in E7 B3 A4 ah this really wants to
trade this is clever because H2 Pawn is
still hanging so you're gonna take over
here
Mission page two and then what did he do
Bishop
ah yeah and that's beautiful I mean I
mean you could go there as well and
guard the G7 was the bishop but he just
highlights that yeah it is at Fortress I
know it's a fortress my Bishop yes there
should be six even when Bishop B6 for a
stalemate that's a funny finish very
nice finish there uh wonderful stalemate
to Camp that one off so were there any
other results that we we've missed no we
still have one game all right we'll
still have one game yeah uh well the one
that there was rook and game remember
that very fast and we were thinking yeah
draw and I said that grand monsters
always make drawers yeah of course
there's no possible way so
you're not gonna tell me Hans is still
playing of course I mean okay I mean
he's suffer porn yeah yeah
is your evaluation changed at all
zero percent will not win this game yeah
all right that's exactly my assessment
but we have one more result as far as I
understand in the group so let me see uh
B group the round's done okay uh how
many draws was in the big group today uh
B group we had uh none you know none
that's zero yeah yeah absolutely every
single game so it's no longer just a
joke that they're playing more decisive
games they're really proven yeah
absolutely they've proven it and the
last I guess last of finish was uh
cartridge yeah no right and I also he
did or do we have Brandon Jacobson who
actually will be able to lead us through
his game against the coming into this
round the tournament leader uh Dennis
cartridge who had a perfect score let's
hear it from Brandon
all right I'm here with Brandon Jacobson
fresh off his win against Dennis cadrich
Brandon you know take me through your
game show me all the sauce and how it
all happened sure yeah so going into the
game I mean I just had a really tough
loss with white the day before
um so I was looking forward to a
fighting game at least to try to
get some
I know get something interesting at
least so
yeah I knew he was mostly an Italian
player and I was pretty happy to see
Bishop G5 because this leads to some
crazy complications and at least I'll
get a chance to fight
um so yeah he was listening in the
opening then he surprised me with A3 I
mean I'm sure it's a move I honestly
didn't prepare this too well but I knew
some of the the general ideas and yeah I
mean it makes sense intuitively like the
idea is just to play a quick B4 B5 and
then break with with D4
um
so I spent a long time here trying to
figure out what to play after A3 I
consider a lot of different ideas even
something like Rook B8 to try to meet B4
with B5 and then I mean there are tons
of options for white like even something
like A4 here is kind of funny because
I mean you get something similar to what
what I've analyzed at least with the
Rook on B8 versus A8 and I was trying to
work out all these little differences
but I decided to just go for a king age
shade pretty kind of principle just
training on net H7 and a quick F5
um
but then he continues blitzing B4 Knight
H7 King H1
and here I have a lot of options
um and I spent a long time trying to
calculate it all I'm not really sure I
made the right decision
um I was my first instinct was to just
go Queen F6 and sort of sort of wait but
the problem here was I thought you can
go D4
and
okay this leads to some crazy
complications if I take on D4 then I
thought he can just take back and stack
the pawn and I think this looks really
dangerous for black like if I if he
takes twice in D4 and goes Rooks he
won't even something like this just felt
pretty dangerous for me
um also if I don't take on D4 and I go
G4 I was even considering something like
B5 here and after G takes F3 just just
taking back sort of these kinds of piece
stacks and looked extremely dangerous
for me because he's taking on E5 next
then he's taking in D6 he gets three
pawns and my king is weak so I was
trying to make sense of all these lines
um but then they decided to just trust
my instincts and go with go with that
five
but then he continues blitzing and takes
on F5 and goes D4
and here I started getting pretty
concerned because
I mean the problem for me is like
it's hard to even find a move because
okay I mean I can win the pawn like I
took on D4 but in the end like my extra
Pawn doesn't mean that much for now and
my king is always going to be super
awake in the long term even if I'm not
getting mated right away
so I did take on D4 uh B5
and yeah I was calculating so many
different lines here I was even trying
to make something like do you take C3 B
takes C6 B5 work okay I see now the
computer actually likes it but I mean in
a real game It seems impossible to
actually make these sort of decisions
um
in the game I went for something greedy
I just took on on D2 and took the extra
pawn and yeah I mean I figured I'm
probably in some trouble here but at
least he'll have to prove something and
honestly I can find a better approach
and yeah here I think he started going a
bit wrong I think he he played a bit too
faster he played Rook au1 which is
logical of course but I think that sort
of misses the point of the position
um 94 was definitely what I was afraid
of because okay sure he's not wanting
the Palm back right away
but I'm pretty sure I have to take and
go Queen F6 for example
and I mean with my weak dark squares I
feel like there's or okay I guess 906 is
probably better but with the dark
squares here long term I mean he's just
gonna get the bishop back into the game
with F3 and Bishop F2 and it feels
really dangerous for me
um so
yeah after Rook A1 I got in Queen F6 it
started to feel a bit more comfortable
for me of course it's still extremely
dangerous with my king super weak but I
started to feel better about my chances
here and he started burning a lot of
time which because I mean at this point
I only had 20 minutes left and he still
had pretty much all his time so when he
started thinking I felt a lot better
around my position so he goes for 95
um Bishop C5 yeah and here it feels like
white should have some way of of
improving his position but it's actually
not easy to to see at all because
yeah okay so he starts with Bishop T5
and he repeats once he goes Queen D5
Rook B2
and yeah I mean this feels good for
white like all your pieces are in the
game but it's really not easy to figure
out
how to continue how to continue here and
if it's my move I'm just going to go
with something like Bishop B6 and queen
G7 and start consolidating so
I mean I think he started panicking a
bit too much here and he played A4 which
felt a bit too slow
um in the game I was much more concerned
about Knight C6
um and yeah I was gonna go something
like Bishop B6
um I expected like 97 let's say
and
like I can play something like Queen D4
and I'm sort of still in the game but I
don't know I mean it feels like a
minimum I can trade and take on F5 and
go rookie seven in the live lines
um and he still has the initiative for
sure
but I think after a for
um
here I started to the consolidate and
again he was already getting a bit low
on time here because division is so wild
it's kind of hard to make these
decisions
um
so yeah I went for H5 when we were low
on time
and
okay yeah I mean I see now the computer
hates it but in the game I wasn't really
sure like what was going on I mean the
only real try for white here seemed to
be F4 and after G4 Bishop H4
and I assume this is what he was
calculating but it gets the total
amounts after Queen takes H4 Knight F7
King G7 Queen takes F5 something I can
throw in G3 I guess can't hurt and then
I thought I could maybe survive this
with something like Queen F6 yeah okay
and I guess the position is still messy
um
I see the computer is changing its mind
about whether I'm lost or I'm still in
the game but at least I thought this was
worth a try when he was getting low on
time
and I think he spent all the time trying
to calculate these complications and
just sort of panicked and played 907 at
the last moment
um what I'm assuming he he missed was
after take take H4
um I I assume that geoscope Bishop B5
and maybe he forgot about some details
like take take Bishop D3 for example and
then Mission P6 and all of my my pieces
um
like all my pieces are well defended
there and he has back rank issues still
so
yeah as a last Stitch after he went for
rookie seven
um but after net F6
yeah H3 take take Bishop E4 he just
resigned here kind of a nice finish
because sort of takes F6 Bishop takes G2
and uh this Bishops speak for themselves
so was it was a nice finish obviously we
love a good nice Bishop that speaks for
itself 50 going in the next round white
pieces against Alexander Linderman how
are you feeling about your game tomorrow
feeling a lot better after this game
obviously not the best technique but it
always feels nice to get it when
especially after a tough loss so
hopefully I'll keep the keep the
momentum going obviously well good luck
tomorrow man hope to see you soon thank
you that was Brandon Jacobson a very
complicated game but at some moments he
just kind of won a bishop perhaps those
some time pressure issues that were
going on uh but it was always nice to
see and that'll bring him up to a 50 uh
percent score and uh we're not quite
done yet all of the games have wrapped
up for the moment and uh you've seen
there you may have seen Hans Neiman
walking around in the background that
game did end in a draw I'm starting to
think that maybe Hans is trying to duck
all of our interviews like he doesn't
care about our ratings it's kind of
ridiculous when he does win a game
though we will definitely get an
interview with him and we actually do
have one last interview with you uh and
this is going to be ronak sadwani who is
the tournament leader for the B section
so it would be fascinating to hear what
he has to say about his game
I am with Grandmaster sadvani fresh off
of his win against Grandmaster tigron
Grandmaster said wani you are plus three
right now you are absolutely killing it
right now tell us all about this game
and tell us all about how it's going
yeah so let's start so I played sifu he
played some E6 93 D5 D4 Knight F6 cd5
ed5 Bishop G5 C6 E3
at 6 patch 4 I never checked this bishop
D6 so it always felt like white will
have at least plus equal or something it
felt comfortable so I played Bishop D3
Castle
Knight D2
rookie it Queen C2 I was also in many
lines intending to go H3 G4 and Castle
long but he just played A5 so after that
it's tough to do it
plate H3 Knight T6 A3 97
I was planning to Castle long but then
he can just play B5 and he's just too
fast so
that's why I just split shot Castle
96 F3 this fight's main plan in this
opening you try for E4 as soon as
possible
so he plays Bishop p7
play Rook 81
trying to get E4
he played B5 which was a strong move
this is how black usually plays in this
line played Bishop F2
he played Bishop A6 played Knight G3 so
my idea here was to get the Knight here
but I see the engine doesn't really like
it but still practically I feel it's a
complicated game
so perfect I played Knight F5 in many
lines my idea was to go Bishop H4 it's
not possible on the next move because of
G6 so I was trying to prepare it he
played B4 Basics Rook A6 Knight F4 here
you cannot really take this Pawn with
the bishop because of Queen D3
and it's a double attack
so he played G6 which makes sense but at
the same time he also weakens his dark
squares
so Knight G3 Queen beard
E4 to be honest this engine evaluation
is surprising me because I thought it
should be very easy to play with white
and white should have at least slightly
better but seems like black is very
solid
okay this was
uh not a great move I was expecting
Knight D7 just to get rid of FIFA and I
thought it's still a game
so he played Rook C8 aventify and here
of course he should go 98 to have more
protection on the F7 Pawn in many lines
he can do this and protect it but
instead what he did was really dangerous
and also it allowed me a lot of
initiative I played F4
it took Bishop should be 396 Queen F2
98
E6 takes Queen C2
if Queen G3 my idea was Rook F3
and if just I was considering if Queen
H4 you just take and this king is
completely gone so
I was expecting King at seven now I'm
gonna touch five with some ideas of
Knight F4 and Knight F6 as well
red Bishop G7 only move I take take go
Knight C5
if he would have taken Knight C5 here I
can just go Bishop F4 or queen C5 both
should win
so Rook A7 I just called ship F4 Queen 8
Queen F2 King Hudson here I thought for
quite some time because I was trying to
find a finish like direct concrete
finish but I couldn't find one so I just
thought I'll do it in the simple way
just take the pawn Knight f8 Knight G5
this queen and this Rook they are doing
nothing so it takes a lot of time for
him to get back now I go Bishop E7
96 Rook F7 Knight G7 rookie one Rook
cheered rookie five threatening Rook H5
taking a shirt
Queen F6 now again threatening Rook H5
gh5 Queen at 6 mate so he goes King at
Sun and Rook G5
and this is how I won my game and it was
a great fight and I'm happy with my
performance so far and with my play
looking forward to six more games
obviously and you got Christopher you
tomorrow with the black pieces yeah how
are you feeling about that matchup I'm
feeling confident for now with two good
games I would say and I hope everything
goes well tomorrow as well well we hope
so too we hope to see you back soon and
good luck see you good luck
what's your feeling after this interview
uh well it sounds like we have I find
this young gentleman to be a very scary
man he's on three out of three and he
says I'm looking for to work next six
games I mean he's playing two good games
in a row he's got three points on the
board three out of three two good games
in a row and he's like casual he says
I'm looking basically to six to win six
more right I mean yeah our obese our B
group actually had two people coming in
here today uh in the lead with two out
of two ironic sadwani who we just saw
that interview with now he's on three
out of three the other leader Dennis
condrich has fallen back and this gives
us a wonderful opportunity to kind of
recap everything and see where everybody
stands so let's go ahead and check out
how we're looking on the standings now
in the a group well at the top of the
leaderboard we have vidit and the Soul
lead with two and a half and at two
points Ilya niznik and Von Nguyen both
of them are doing an excellent
tournament Von to win with a big win
today then at one and a half we got you
Yang Yi hanzan and Gregory or paranon
nijot amsavanda after that on one point
we got armhakobi and Nicholas theodoro
and getting on the board today was Surya
Ganguly so good to see everybody now
with at least some points so tell me
Meryl what's going on in the B group uh
while in the B group as you uh mentioned
ralnak is the sole leader well pursuited
by Christopher you and Alex Lindemann
who have died for the second with two
and a half Dennis cartridge has lost his
uncle fourth position with two out of
three uh while gergelicanta Brandon
Jacobson on 50
1.40 Grand harutinyan and Armand
Michelin still still early
to get on the board but uh I think this
was actually one of the more exciting
days that was really incredible stuff so
a huge thank you to everybody that's
been staying with us we see you on
Twitch we see you on YouTube uh when
we're signing off for the day this was
wonderful I hope you guys come back
because things only get more and more
exciting especially as we go along so
join us again at 4 P.M tomorrow and we
will see you for another exciting round
of the Fall chess classic uh yep see you
people join tomorrow please
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited